Well first, we're going to jump
in the TikTok time machine,
going back to the nineties.
Apartment Therapy reports that a man
in Iowa built a retro video rental store
in his basement.
And he shared a tour on Tik Tok.
It's not a business.
Unfortunately we can't go.
It's just a fun nostalgic bunker for family and friends.
And he did it for his kids.
So I have to say,
you know, being inspired
especially right now, when we're all stuck at home
he gets like the father of the year award.
Cause that is just so incredibly inventive.
It's very cool.
And I would love to go in and explore.
I missed, I missed like the Blockbuster
that kind of store, you know,
I would do like the music store.
Remember going to get a CD?
Oh, of course I do.
By the way, I used to work at a Music Plus.
When?
Yeah, my boss was named Whitney.
He could not stand me.
He was like a total Hasher rocker.
He had like the, he looked like Frampton, you know.
Can I just do like a time out?
Like at what point in your life?
Like when did you do that?
Like, I don't know, 12, and I took the bus to work
and you know, I just, I wanted to work
at a job and no one was calling me for a job.
So I tried working at Music Plus,
and I'll tell you something.
I was good at recommending movies,
and people would come in and be like
I saw this movie that has this guy in this house.
I'd be like, this is the one you're talking about.
I was good at my job.
Oh you're good.
Of course you were cause you like, you're a curator.
You like to give people advice.
I was the host on Turner Classic Movies, The Essentials.
I know movies.
I love movies, Whitney.
(laughs)
Oh my God, Whitney's losing it right now.
All right, Drew.
I think he still hates me.
You know, everyone's on Zoom these days, right?
And so have you ever been on a Zoom call
and thought, you know, if I just sit really still
maybe they'll like not notice that
or they think I'm frozen
and I can hang up and like bounce?
You ever?
Mmhmm.
Kind of like when you call someone
on a cell phone, you're like, I can't, I can't what darn it.
You would just hang up pretending like it's
I'm cutting out right now.
I can't.
Yes. Well, if you've done that
then you're going to love this.
The Verge says you can now download something
called a Zoom Escaper, which is a program
that helps you secretly sabotage your video calls.
Here's how it works.
You download it and you set it up.
And then the next time you're on a Zoom
you can click on it to add like an annoying echo
or make your voice sound like you have a bad connection.
We actually have an example.
Take a listen.
I can add echo my voice so I can make
myself myself echo.
Feedback. Feedback.
So you can totally fake a technical difficulty.
You can add a dog barking, Jackhammer,
even a man weeping for some reason.
True story.
I got to go take care of this man.
Who's crying in my house.
I want to know, would you try this
or how do you feel about Zoom in general?
Are you over it?
It, you know, we all have Zoom fatigue.
There's so many things that I think it works better
and more efficiently for
but it is probably not for living an entire life on.
I'm not going to lie.
I have faked the bad signal.
You have?
I have.
So, you know, maybe listen, listen, it's happened.
Sometimes you've gotta go.
Sometimes we all want a little extra raw sauce though
on the news sandwich.
And guess what?
We have a segment we're calling The Ross Report.
Okay!
♪ It's the Ross Report. ♪
I'll have you know I wrote that song too.
Ah, all right.
So here's the deal. Ross Report.
I'm going to be bringing you the full scoop on some stuff
that's on my radar.
And today we're going to do a deep dive on TJs.
I'm not talking Tijuana.
Trader Joe's Egon.
It's a phenomenon.
It's been ranked the top grocery store
in the country by consumers.
There's always products trending.
There's fans accounts.
Trader Joe's list is one that people like.
They have 1.5 million followers, Drew.
It's smaller than your average supermarket.
But the special thing about them is
that 80% of their products are their private brand.
They're good.
And they're affordable.
You know, I've lost like almost 60 pounds
in the past year trying to cook for myself.
And one of the things that I cook literally
four times a week is tacos, but I take
out the tortilla and instead I use this Jicama Wrap.
Now jicama is like that root vegetable, right?
And TJ sells them slice like this.
Thin, thin.
So it's almost like a lettuce wrap they're,
they're cold.
It also has like an
a little bit of a really nice like crunch.
Yes. So here's what I do.
And I actually have a choose your own adventure thing
over here of beans and guac and hot sauce.
I do black beans.
I cook them just with whatever you want.
You can do onions or garlic.
And then I do my protein
like ground turkey with taco seasoning, ground chicken.
You could do salmon, whatever.
I love a taco seasoning.
And then a little hot sauce.
And you're going to love this so much
because if you're trying to like, watch what you're eating
you could have like eight of these
which I do like for dinner and it's zero points
or whatever calories.
Well, I have to say, Rossi
your transformation has been really extraordinary.
I mean, my daughter and I, as you know
all of who like always comes and checks you out and is like
because she loves Drag Race
and I'm looking at even just the last season,
and it's, it's just your discipline.
My goodness.
Well, you know, I call it my recipes, Ross-ipies
because I want it to taste really good
but I want it to be good for me.
And you're trying that for the first time.
Can we talk about the Jicama Wrap?
I was already a fan of jicama,
but a lot of the times I'll do tacos in lettuce wraps
but this is a whole new ball game.
I have to tell you I'm obsessed with it.
So when I thought what I want to bring to the table
at Drew's News for a Ross Report,
I wanted to share with you something
I literally eat four, five times a week.
So just try it, okay?
Well, I have to say as someone who is a major fluctuater.
I'm on like the seesaw from hell, most of the time
there is a way that you can substitute ingredients
and make life really fun while you eat healthy.
Diets are something that anyone is going to rebel
against after awhile.
Part of our pleasure in life is food.
You cannot eat chicken and broccoli
for the rest of your life.
It just doesn't work.
And it's going to make you go off the rails.
So you've got to find these like great alternatives,
and they're out there.
And they have to be fun.
That's why I like this as something so basic
then you can mix up what you put in it every single night.
You can be different.
When you know how much we love curating and just trying
to bring new ideas and things to people's lives.
So this is brilliant.
Well, the stuff you bring me in the doggy bag
I literally bring home and try and use.
So I just want to contribute back to you.
Well (barks)
(Upbeat music)